[Music]
it's
okay so
look
internal fo
grounding
internal just
then as you go I stay whoa two
too much right go back
integrate internal
external so go back it's not just
getting out the
way so I'm going to change my angle you
see and then when I go to throw it's
going to be
internal okay so it's
not
just get out of the way it's not going
to work you
[Music]
understand so you getting get you feel
like
whoa integrating external then go back
to
[Music]
internal understand so you integrate the
two like you didn't
WR so
theoretically whenever you cannot
internalize you
externalize until you can re internalize
but even as you go
external it's always a little internal
in it like the yinong symbol you got it
can't be completely external or your
performance envelope was way down like
that one time okay so if you're not sure
what I'm talking about I'm just going to
move my shoulders down do get it and
I'll let all the wait till we get there
I'm going to let all the external all
the internals go dead so
here it didn't eff work see
that